(wind howling)
(birds chirping)
(“Imagine” by John Lennon)
♫ Imagine there's no heaven
♫ It's easy if you try
♫ No hell below us
♫ Above us only sky
♫ Imagine all the people
♫ Living for today
♫ Ah-ah-ahh
♫ Imagine there's no countries
♫ It isn't hard to do
♫ Nothing to kill or die for
♫ And no religion, too
♫ Imagine all the people
♫ Living life in peace
♫ You
♫ You may say I'm a dreamer
♫ But I'm not the only one
♫ I hope someday you will join us
♫ And the world will be as one
♫ Imagine no possessions
♫ I wonder if you can
♫ No need for greed or hunger
♫ A brotherhood of man
♫ Imagine all the people
♫ Sharing all the world
♫ You
♫ You may say I'm a dreamer
♫ But I'm not the only one
♫ I hope someday you will join us
♫ And the world will live as one
(birds chirping)
(wind howling)